Speaker 1: All right.
So now we're going to wrap up the entire Trump
portion of the show.
This is a really important update on a story
from last week.
Last week, you might remember that The New
York Times is Maggie Haberman tweeted an absolutely
outrageous story, which was that Donald Trump
has been telling people around him that he
believes he's going to be reinstated to the
White House as soon as August of this year.
Now, as a reminder, Habermann tweeted, quote,
Trump has been telling a number of people
he's in contact with that he expects he will
be reinstated by August.
No, that isn't how it works.
But simply sharing the information going on
to say that it isn't happening in a vacuum.
It is happening as he faced the possibility
of an indictment from the Manhattan district
attorney and then lastly, adding that, quote,
He is not putting out statements about the
audits in states just for the sake of it.
He's been laser focused on them, according
to several people who've spoken with him,
as well as Washington Post reporting a few
weeks ago.
Now, when this story broke last week, a whole
bunch of people started immediately calling
it fake news.
And Trump's blog right before it shut down
also had a post where Donald Trump was denying
it.
But since then, the story has been corroborated.
And the truth, as it often is with Trump,
is even crazier than the reality.
The right wing National Review, not a left
wing bomb throwing publication, not a publication
that Trump has been calling fake news.
The right wing National Review published a
story called Maggie Haberman is Right, which
actually tells an even crazier story, reporting
that it's not only Trump who thinks he's going
to be reinstated, it's Trump and two Republican
senators as well.
Charles Cook writes in the piece, quote, Instead,
They should have listened because Haberman's
reporting was correct.
I can attest from speaking to an array of
different sources that Donald Trump does indeed
believe quite genuinely that he, along with
former Senators David Perdue and Martha McSally,
will be reinstated to office this summer after
audits of the 2020 elections in Arizona, Georgia
and a handful of other states have been completed.
I can attest to that.
Trump is trying hard to recruit journalists,
politicians and other influential figures
to promulgate this belief not as a fundraising
tool or an infantile bit of trolling or a
trial balloon, but as a fact.
This is nuts.
My friends.
And the article goes on to say, and remember,
this is the conservative National Review saying
this.
The article goes on to say, The scale of Trump's
delusion is quite startling.
This is not merely an eccentric interpretation
of the facts or an interesting foible, nor
is it an irrelevant example of anguished post
presidency chatter.
It is a rejection of reality, a rejection
of law, and ultimately a rejection of the
entire system of American government.
There is no reinstatement clause within the
United States Constitution.
Hell, there is nothing even approximating
a reinstatement clause within the United States
Constitution.
The election has been certified.
Joe Biden is the president.
And until 2024, that is all there is to it
doesn't matter what one's view of Trump is,
doesn't matter whether one voted for or against
Trump.
It doesn't matter whether one's view one views
Trump's role within the Republican Party favorably
or unfavorably.
We are talking here about cold, hard, neutral
facts that obtain, irrespective of one's preferences.
It is not too much to ask that the former
head of the executive branch should understand
them.
This is why I said earlier in the show a new
litmus test, a sort of a gut check, sanity
check question to right wingers should be
going forward.
What is the soonest you believe Donald Trump
could again be?
President Trump says he's going to be restarting
rallies as soon as this month.
Send reporters to the rallies and say to them,
sir, ma'am, what is the soonest you believe
Donald Trump could be president?
And if it's any earlier than January of twenty
twenty five, it's someone either living in
a fantasy world or someone very, very ignorant.
So not only was Maggie Haberman correct in
her reporting, not only has that been corroborated,
it is not Trump alone, but also David Perdue
and Martha McSally.
Who believe, I guess, that they're going to
be reinstated to their Senate seats somehow
sometime during the summer.
These are really dangerous times, especially
because and we'll talk about this tomorrow
when this stuff inevitably doesn't happen.
Will the Trump acolytes again be moved to
real world violence and destruction of property
and breaking and entering and trespassing
and violence that we saw on January six?
That's the really scary part.
And we'll probably talk more about that tomorrow